[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes from
spectator tv
recorded on thursday december the 3rd
it's been a dramatic week a vaccine is
on its way it's arriving next week
herod by a flurry of johnsonian
metaphors
will it quell tory backbench anger at
multi-tier lockdowns
is already provoked the government's
biggest parliamentary
rebellion yet if it wasn't for labor
abstentions disgruntled tory mps
would have overturned even its 80-seat
majority
i'll be speaking to their ringleader the
rebel ringleader former whip
mark harper a new poll put support for
scottish independence at 56 percent
is the momentum behind scottish
nationalism now unstoppable
emily gray is the ipsos mori poster
behind this week's numbers and will be
joining the show
and finally our third segment today the
language of so-called critical race
theory
it's permeated many conversations this
year fueling the
black lives matter movement triggering a
backlash
from some more conservative politicians
but what is
critical race theory and is there
anything to learn from it
i'll be asking trevor phillips former
chairman of the equality and human
rights commission
now before we kick off a reminder to
subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel for free
then you'll never miss a new episode of
spectator tv just
hit the subscribe button it's at the
bottom right corner
and as always we make a special thanks
to charles stanley
for supporting this episode of the week
in 60 minutes
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms
for one of the oldest companies on the
london stock exchange
so our first item today 55 tory mps
rebelled against the government and a
vote
on returning england to the three-tier
lockdown system
mark harper a former chief whip he's now
the ringleader
of the backbench rebels joins the show
show shortly
but before that let's chew over the
week's developments with the spectators
political editor james forsythe
our deputy political editor katie balls
and our economies correspondent
kate andrews uh james uh place
this rebellion the tuesday vote in
context how
significant was it given that the
government wasn't actually defeated
it is the biggest rebellion of boris
johnson's premiership
it was a rebellion that was so large
that if the opposition parties had not
sat on their hands but opposed the
government the government would have
lost
it clearly is significant it's also
significant because it's part of a
trend the number of tory rebels against
these coveted measures have
been rising consistently when the um
the act the coronavirus which gave the
government its emergency powers
was passed in march it was past the
march about a vote because there was
essentially unanimity
across the house when those powers came
to be renewed in september
only seven tories voted against it uh
then 42 tories voted against the 10 pm
curfew and various other measures and
you've now seen
uh 53 tory rebels uh uh on
uh this measure and i think it is quite
clear
from anyone listening to the debate in
the house of commons and what's been
said from the government from the
dispatch box
but if this when this tier system comes
back for a vote in the comments at the
end of january if
quite a few places haven't moved down
the tiers if there hasn't been more of
an
effort made to disaggregate uh
places with low infections from areas of
high infection so for example
splitting off west kent from those
medway towns or
north somerset from bristol then i think
the tory rebellion
will be bigger and i think that the
question for boris johnson is
yeah how quickly can they get these
vaccines
rolled out and then approved and does
that
help to quell the rebellion because i i
think if the last
vote on the tier system is the one at
the end of january it renews it and then
we see a significant easing up in march
before a lifting of all the restrictions
in april
this period boris johnson's been able to
put this period behind him quite quickly
with his parliamentary party
but if the vaccine rollout is bumpy if
it takes time
if we end up with restrictions still
being in place after easter
and the government having to have
several more votes on the tiers i think
these rebellions are just going to keep
getting bigger
katie the the government obviously had
wind
of the rebellion and that it was going
to be on some
scale we understand that boris johnson
stood at the division
uh lobby door in the commons appealing
to rebels not to vote
do we know if that was a plus or
reminders for his case
well those around him alleged it was an
effective performance from the prime
minister
and one of a serious series of measures
that they uh put in place throughout the
day to
to reduce the size of the rebellion for
example
um before boris johnson went you know
just trying to almost uh
suggest to people as they walked where
they where they should go
you had an impromptu zoom meeting that
the prime minister called of his chief
whip
where tory mps at the last minute were
invited to tune in
you know an hour or so before the vote
so he could address them
and in that his message was quite simple
he said uh ultimately
unity is really important for the tory
party for the government
and don't give labor the satisfaction of
seeing a disunited tory party
and i think that's interesting because
some of the tory rebels want to say yo
you know this isn't a party politics
this is a
issue which doesn't have long
implications for boris johnson
you know it's just coronavirus but the
fact that boris johnson made that
argument himself
about how this would look shows how
number 10 do see this rebellion which is
something which is worrying to boris
johnson's authority
kate one of the arguments of the rebels
is the economic
damage that a second lockdown is doing
we know that the british economy
bounced back a fair bit in the third
quarter after the terrible
second quarter but it was beginning to
peter out
uh towards the end of september as more
lockdowns came in
are we able to see yet what the economic
damage of the
that what i might call the second
lockdown has been
uh no we don't know yet although there
have been some estimates that
non-essential retail were losing out on
2 billion pounds a week there are
questions as
to as to whether or not debenhams which
uh
has has fallen under this week is a
result of lockdown or whether or not
that's just a result of a business going
under and as we say in this week's
spectator leader that's not necessarily
a bad thing part of the market process
is
failure and debenhams was in
administration in spring last year it's
clearly not
just covet that's affected that business
but the problem is that
when we look at business closures right
now we're not looking at any of them in
isolation we're looking at them
at a time where you've had extreme
restrictions especially
on on retail and it's very difficult to
say that this would have naturally
happened or certainly not
at this pace and of course it's not just
uh uh
shops and that are you know selling
clothes and
and objects it's it's it's uh pubs and
restaurants as well
um it's estimated at the moment that
over 50 000
licensed um pubs and restaurants may not
be reopening
even though we're out of lockdown now
because only two two percent of pubs
are in tier one areas um so this is a
lot of the data that we're going to get
in the coming months and
next year it's thought that's going to
be when the hardship really shows itself
employment peaking at 7.5 percent it's
estimated
uh not just by the office for budget
responsibility last week but now by the
oecd
this week james the prime minister's now
said there'll be fortnightly
reviews of the system who's in what
tier and so on but is it is it
seriously the intention that there will
be major
movement of regions between tiers as a
result of these reviews or is it
is it just an attempt to placate the
rebels
so i think when the system was
originally announced
the expectation certainly among
government scientific advisors
was that there wouldn't be very much
movement because there is this this
christmas easing this five days where up
to three households be allowed to mix
we know that the scientific advisors
think that that is likely to send
uh the case rate up and therefore they
wanted to keep things
as tight as possible in the run-up to
that now
i think there might be some movement uh
i think you for example greater
manchester its cases are coming down
it might move from tier three to tier
two at that point
possibly there'll be some attempt to
detach some places
uh from urban areas with high levels of
infection
that appears to have very low levels of
infection themselves
but i think the reality is that these
five if these
uh five days of christmas easing have
anything like the effect
that uh the scientific advice expect we
know that people on stage
think that for every one day of
christmas easing you need
five days of title restrictions
afterwards to compensate
then i think it is hard to see but when
parliament uh
when these reviews take place in january
but they'll be losing
lots of places down the tier system and
i think you see another sign of concern
with the plan announced today that
university students will return in a
staggered fashion with some not making
it back to university until
the beginning of february i think that
is because the last thing
that the government wants to see is that
that spike you saw when universities
went
uh back in in mid uh september
combining with the post-festive period
increase now
the risk of the festive period is
obviously that people will travel around
the country and so move from low
infection areas to high infection areas
uh and back again and so i think i mean
the big
question now is you know what happens
there and i think the other massive
question
which the deputy chief medical officer
jonathan van tam touched on this morning
is
when is this oxford vaccine approved if
the regulator approves that before
christmas i think that does change
things because
that means that the uk can set about a
policy of attempting to vaccinate
every adult who wants to be vaccinated
and it can set about try and
it doesn't need to work out precisely
who gets
it you know it doesn't need to ration it
it can just flood the
flood the zone with this vaccine and i
think that might enable you to eat to
eat starts
doing some serious easing late february
early march
and that might help duplicate mark and
some of his colleagues who i think their
worry is that these measures will just
kind of
continue on and on it'll be like
rationing after the war there won't be a
moment when these goes
and i think that's why at his press
conference last night boris johnson who
doesn't like disagreeing publicly with
his scientists
went out of his way to say that he
didn't agree with
uh van tan when van tam suggested that
some of the measures that have been put
in place
to deal with coronavirus might well stay
in place even after people have been
vaccinated
well you mentioned mark harper james
he's with us now one of those
backbenchers uh who rebelled he was
chief whip
under david cameron that's a job in
which you meant to suppress rebellion
but today he leads the newly formed
covert recovery group it's a merry band
of covert
skeptic tory mps or at least locked down
skeptic tory mps
uh mark harper welcome to spectator tv
so you're
you're a game turned poacher now what
happened
well look for me there's a range of
people in
in our group but for me primarily this
was about
not feeling the government had been uh
as open and transparent with mps
as i think it should have been on two
sides um
one of them is just about the measures
that are being proposed
and how effective we're going to they're
going to be and from my point of view is
i'm
rather disappointed by the level of
information we've seen put out
about the modelling about how each of
the measures was chosen so for example
hospitality
there's very little evidence that
there's been significant spread of
of covid in hospitality venues um very
few of them have been
um pinned on track and trace there's
very little academic evidence there's a
little bit now that's been published
around ventilation
but the government hasn't engaged with
the industry about ventilation
and my argument is if you've got covid's
secure guidelines and you're telling
businesses to invest money
and they can operate safely then why
can't they operate safely if you really
think they can't operate safely at all
whatever they do then then shut them
down but then you have to compensate
them properly and the problem at the
moment in tier three areas they're shut
tier two areas they're able to trade but
we're not allowing people to go to them
unless
you go to people with your household so
there's a real issue there for me about
have we got the measures right
and for me it's not just about um are
they too tough
it's are they going to work and you've
just been talking about christmas so i
have a real concern about
whether does it make sense to tighten
things up
relax them at christmas potentially have
a whole month of restrictions with
massive costs
now it may be the right thing to do but
i haven't seen
any sense of data or information or any
sense the government's weighed that
up properly they may have done but
they've not shared that with members of
parliament and i think
for this level of issue you do then just
finally
picking up on on kate's point about the
economics
the government's analysis that it
published this week was very
disappointing it was
some cut and paste work from the obr
they didn't even share
information which they know we know
they've got that was in the times
and i know that time story was true
because someone sent me
some extracts of those documents so i
know they exist but they weren't shared
with us by the government so my
argument's about being open and
transparent so that we know we're
getting these decisions
as right as you can humanly get them
we're not going to get perfect
information
because this is a you know these are
difficult decisions
but for me i don't think the
government's done that job and
and didn't persuade me um that was the
view of many of my colleagues others had
different
reasons for not supporting the
government i don't want to be in this
position i want to be in the position in
january
where i can support the government and i
hope the government learns from this
vote this week and ups its game a bit
ahead of that vote in january
and when you put to the government that
it should be more transparent that you
should see the data that was referred to
in the times
what do they say well i think it's two
things
first we have seen um with the recent
personnel changes there's definitely
been a tone
a total change in the government the
prime minister's letters to us
both the one that went to all mps and
the one that went to
myself and steve baker and members of
our group um
was certainly i think quite uh
collegiate in tone
um but cummings is no longer writing
them
you might say that andrea i couldn't
possibly comment um
but the tone was good but the substance
we didn't really see any shift in
substance but my
argument is we need to see all the
information out there
let members of parliament and the public
look at these trade-offs there are
trade-offs here they are difficult ones
but i think if you're open and honest
with people even if they don't like the
choices you've made
if they can see how you've arrived at
them you've got a much better chance
of taking people with you and ultimately
dealing with this virus
is about people's behavior it it's about
people's behavior
social distancing wearing face masks and
how they behave
but even coming back to james's point
it's about people's behavior with the
vaccine it's about making sure we
maximize the number of people
that are willing to have the vaccine
it's about making sure that
as we get the vaccine rolled out to the
riskiest groups those that are most
likely to suffer from
getting covered we can then reduce the
restrictions on everybody else so
it's about people's behavior which means
taking people with you
and that's why i think an open and
transparent approach a more open
and transparent approach is the right
one to take but in strategic terms the
government would say look our second
lockdown
has managed to get on top of the second
wave of covert
we've now moved to a tier structure
we've got this vaccine coming it starts
to
roll out next week there are more on the
way
we've had to loosen up for christmas
that was basically responding to public
demand or
i feel that the public was going to do
what it wanted anyway at christmas so
they
came up with some kind of rules that
will inevitably lead
to another spike in covert cases so we
need to keep the tier system back in
but as this vaccine rolls out we can
move
others to tier two to tier one and
eventually get rid of it we have a
strategic way forward
don't don't mess with it well it's very
interesting andrew
you've set out uh what sounds like a
very coherent narrative there
i haven't actually heard a single
government minister
lay out that coherent strategic
narrative actually
um which is part of my argument so we
don't yet know
uh how quickly we're going to be able to
roll out the vaccine so this is a
different we keep hearing about easter
from easter that we're going to be in a
significantly
more normal situation but when you
listen to some of the scientists chief
scientific advisor for example
they're cautioning it may well take the
best pass of
six months next year to get people
sufficiently vaccinated
we don't know whether how far down the
list of
the priority groups you've got to go
before
you can sensibly relax restrictions um
significantly
we don't yet know whether the vaccine
actually stops people transmitting
covid or whether it just deals with
stopping people getting severe symptoms
or symptoms
so there's lots of questions we don't
yet have the answer to
and i think that's why colleagues are
nervous i think if the government was a
bit more open about its thinking
and about the trade-offs your trade-off
discussion there about christmas
the government hasn't actually said any
of those things it hasn't
openly said it thinks people
would have just done what they wanted
anyway so it's relaxing things for
christmas
and it hasn't said because of that it's
having to keep things tougher as james
said it's hinting
it's going to relax things before
christmas i agree with james i don't
think there's going to be any
significant easing before christmas
and i think if christmas the effects of
christmas are
are not good and they're like we've seen
some other countries uh for
thanksgiving for example in in canada uh
you might see those restrictions have to
say in place through the whole of
january
but i think part of the problem is if
people ministers leveled with us
in the way you just have i think a lot
of us would have been much more
reassured and possibly wouldn't have had
to vote against the government
this week that's interesting maybe uh
maybe i should have applied for that job
as a government spokesman but there was
no chance of that
either of me applying that's probably
right or getting it
um putting processor hide or even
aside or even issues of transparency
aside
are you clear in your own mind what
policy
change would you like to see from the
government when it comes to lockdowns
and
and tears what do you think it should do
differently from what it's doing now
well i think i think there's a really
issue about lockdowns and one of the
things we know from the first one
is that the government's own analysis
says that the impact of the lockdown and
the recession it calls
if you take into account morbidity so
disease not just mortality
people dying the impact of that lockdown
and the recession it caused
is going to be bigger and more severe
in terms of what are called quality
adjusted life years
than actually the number of people that
died from covid in that period
so that's pretty that's pretty important
and we've learned some lessons from that
so the second lockdown you know
we didn't shut down the health service
we didn't clear out people from elective
surgery actually the health service
did a fantastic job of keeping open for
routine surgery and keeping people
coming through the door
so that should have reduced the cost of
that lockdown but i don't
what i don't see is the trade-offs being
made
about what are the costs the long-term
cost the economic cost
because you know if we drive down the
size of the economy
and we throw people out of work that has
we know that has a health impact
we know it has an impact on chronic
illnesses
and i just don't see any sense that
we're balancing those things there are
no easy choices here i accept that
but i want to know that governments
properly balance these issues
um and has properly weighed them up uh
when it's reached its decisions and to
be honest if i thought that had happened
in government if i thought that process
had
taken place i would be much more
likely to give the government the
benefit of the doubt but everything i
read
in the newspapers about how these
decisions are being made and what i know
from my own
contacts suggests to me that
that process isn't taking place which is
why i'm afraid i think parliament's
having to do the job
that frankly should be taking place
inside government how much concern
happiness is there on the conservative
back benches
about the government's overall
performance
in dealing with covert well i'd say two
things
i think first of all that there is there
are a lot of people who are not very
happy about the position we're in but a
lot of that's to do with the virus not
to do with the government and i think
there's a lot of people who think
including myself who think that
these have been incredibly difficult
decisions and there are no easy answers
and yes mistakes have been made but
frankly no human being
would have not made mistakes during this
position so i think there's still quite
a lot of good will
and that's why i'm frustrated that the
government hasn't been more open
and tried to take mps with it i think if
it was more open and tried to take
mps with it shared information more
shared the decision-making process more
did what michael gove said for example i
agree with him mp
should take responsibility for these
decisions
but we can't be expected to take
responsibility if the government's not
as
open as it can be about sharing the
information it has
i think mps will be much more inclined
to give the government the benefit of
the doubt to be perfectly honest
um but i think to give the government
the benefit of the doubt i think it
requires the government to be more open
and transparent about how it's making
these decisions
final uh question uh for you where does
the rebellion go from here
what happens next well i very much hope
i mean
i i i will you know keep working with
the government i hope we can persuade
the government to become more open and
transparent
between now and the end of january james
talks about the fact there needs to be
another vote at the end of january these
these regulations expire
at the beginning of february so there
has to be another vote at the end of
january i hope we're in a position then
where the government can set out its its
strategy in much the same way you did
will hopefully be some way down the
process of being able to vaccinate the
most vulnerable groups
and hopefully in a position at the end
of january where what's being proposed
for the for the next couple of months
after that we can see a significant
easing of restrictions
uh get the economy starting to to bounce
back again
and obviously a significant number of
people will have been protected
from the virus by vaccination and i
think if government leveled with us and
set out even if there were more
restrictions to come
but we could see a proper road map i i
think colleagues will be
in much better shape and i'll do what i
can to try and get us into that position
as i said i'm not as
you mentioned i was a former government
chief whip i'm not by inclination
wanting to lead rebellions that doesn't
come naturally to me i'd much
rather be able to get the government in
a position where i was able to support
it and that's what i will
continue working to do in the weeks to
come
mark harper thank you for joining us
today on spectator tv it's been good
to talk to you before we move on i just
like to remind you to subscribe to the
spectators
youtube channel it's free and then
you'll never miss a show
uh of spectator tv just hit the
subscribe button in the bottom
right corner now in the time before
covered that was
uh bc there were some who thought the
snp
destined to fall from its pedestal even
if only on the basis that no governing
party can remain so dominant for so long
and the snp has been dominant for 13
years
but since the pandemic hit nicholas
sturgeon's popularity
has grown and a new ipsy's maury poll
this week put support for scottish
independence at 56 percent
the surgeon paradox is our cover story
this week in the spectator
and i'm joined now by emily gray she's
managing director
of ipsos maurice scotland emily welcome
to spectator tv
can you just go through the numbers for
us first
absolutely thanks for the welcome andrew
though these are our latest ipsos mori
poll findings
on how people would vote in scotland in
in next may's scottish parliament
elections so this chart shows the
constituency vote
and the snp are riding high so
more than twice as many people say that
they would vote
snp as would vote conservative and when
we look at the second list vote
then that the story is similar and that
as you say that's it's really
astonishing to see that level of support
for a political party
after 13 and a half years in in power
when we look at the independence
question there is a clear lead for
independence in our latest poll
and every poll that's been taken since
the start of june
has shown a lead for yes to independence
but it's worth saying that that while
that's
built during the course of the pandemic
it's something that
started earlier when you look at the
trend on scottish independence
it has been you know support for
independence has been building over time
and we can talk about the factors work
behind that
i think part of it is also to do with
with brexit
obviously scotland voted most scots
voted to to remain
but we shouldn't forget that at the same
time independence is not the top issue
on people's minds so
in some vicious murray's other polling
what we see is of course people are most
worried about the coronavirus but
it's issues like economy the the nhs
education
that are you know more at the forefront
of people's minds independence actually
comes quite far down the list of
people's concerns so always worth
remembering that
next slide please
so we asked people across scotland how
much they trusted
each of the main political parties to
deal effectively
with a whole range of key issues and
what we found was that the snp was the
most trusted party
on every single one of those issues and
that includes issues like education down
the bottom there
where the snp's record has been the
target of a lot of criticism
but that doesn't seem to be cutting
through very much
at the moment with with the public
across scotland
to you know three in five of us still
trust the snp to manage education in
schools
next slide please and when you look at
how the conservatives are doing in
scotland the picture is
kind of flipped so a third or fewer of
scots say that they trust the scottish
conservatives to deal effectively with
these issues
and that's even the case on the economy
which traditionally would have been
perceived
you know would have been perceived as a
relative strength of the conservatives
i think these numbers are quite
difficult for for conservatives and for
unionists
and i do think they they relate in part
to
boris johnson's real unpopularity in
scotland as well
uh next slide please
but of course all of this is very very
far from being being settled
and we were keen to look at people's
strength of opinion on staying part of
the uk
or independence and what we found there
is
around a quarter of people still haven't
completely made up their minds
so you have you know and and so don't
have a completely definitive position on
whether scotland should stay part of the
uk
or or come out and i think that's that's
really important to remember and it's
that middle ground
i think that shows us that both that yes
campaigners cannot be complacent
even though these numbers look very good
for the snp and for independence
and also that you you know it also i
think gives a glimmer of hope for
unionists as well as i say this is very
far from settled
thank you for that the fascinating
figures emily how comfortable are you
with the question should scotland be an
independent
country uh because of course it leaves
a multitude of things unanswered
independent outside europe inside europe
independent with what currency
its own currency stalling the euro and
and so and so on and
during the culvert crisis many scots
might have concluded that scotland
effectively is an independent country
already uh watching nicola sturgeon on
bbc scotland every day
well it's true that devolution has been
more more visible
evolution in action has been more
visible than ever before
in scotland over the course of the
pandemic you know you see
decisions taken and taken in scotland
that are affecting people's day-to-day
lives and i think that's been that
has been quite powerful in terms of
public opinion
uh but you know of course this is the
question that was asked back in 2014
and so as you would expect continue
polling on that but when you look at
devolution more widely
i think what it shows you on public
opinion is that most scots
are in favor of devolution so we can
look at the different forms of that
it's all we also looked uh quite
recently at
what people felt with a with the most
compelling argument
either for independence or for staying
part of the uk
and you know of course the economic
risks of independence still play out
strongly as a reason for staying part of
the uk
but i think there's also a question of
you know where is the positive case for
the union and who
and who makes that and you know so for
example one thing we found
is that the argument that across the uk
we have more in common than divides us
actually can be quite powerful for
people but it's not an argument that i
think scots are really hearing from
at the moment no so there's a there's a
lot of messages for the union aside in
europe
too basically to get their act together
and get a hearing message i mean the
scottish national party has a coherent
message
you might not like it but nobody we
we're in no doubt what it stands for
the water one who wants to do in terms
of the general
uh vision it is interesting though when
you look at
the the your slide on
the snp being trusted on education and
in health
because when you look at the figures to
take the handling of covet uh nicola
sturgeon has certainly
not done it better than boris johnson
and may even have done it worse as
andrew
marr put to her on the bbc of the
weekend on a whole range of educational
uh
parameters uh metrics um
the smp has not delivered on the famous
attainment gap in particular
it hasn't narrowed the performance
between the poorest kids
uh and the the most uh affluent kids
health we know the classic examples of
the hospital in glasgow where people
have been picking up terrible
diseases and even dying in the
children's hospital embracing
i don't think it's still not even opened
yet but none of that seems to matter
when
when people reply to you paul is that
because the media in scotland isn't
telling them anything
anything about this i think it has
much to do with leadership and
communication during the pandemic
so we know that nicola sturgeon's
ratings have stayed
pretty high over the course of the
pandemic whereas that's not been the
case for boris johnson in
in scotland or across the or across the
uk
but i think it's it's also around that
more cautious approach
to managing the pandemic that the
scottish government has taken
and i think that's really chimed with
how people have been feeling day to day
in scotland because people have been
scared people have been anxious
and that kind of more cautious approach
you know rightly wrongly has
you know does seem to have cut through
have you done any
questioning any pulling on would you
like to be independent
but rejoin the eu and take the euro
it's it's an it's an interesting
question of that and i think
the thing is that it will be such a high
it'd be a very hypothetical situation at
the moment
but what we did look at in our latest
poll was how people were feeling about
brexit
and you know as you would expect the
majority of scots were feeling
pessimistic about the likely impacts of
french because they voted two to one for
remain
yeah though it's been a slow burn that
issue i mean i think nicola sturgeon in
the early days after 2016
was surprised that the brexit referendum
in which
scottish votes were basically
overwhelmed well scottish remain votes
were overwhelmed by english
leave votes i think she was surprised it
didn't move
the dial so much in her direction
but the evidence now is it's been a slow
burn and it perhaps is
moving in her direction now that the
brexit referendum
has helped her case and to be clear this
latest shift to independence
towards support for independence over
the last year or so
is not about brexit so its support has
increased both among levers and
remainers to pretty much the same extent
it's down to other factors i think the
pandemic is has been a big factor in
that
emily gray managing director of ipsis
maurice scotland thank you for joining
us and sharing these
poll numbers with us fascinating stuff
james let me come straight to you
um the government the unionists they
clearly know they've got a
big problem on their hands uh
do they have any idea what to do about
it so i think they have some idea
so i think it is as close as anything is
to being a certainty in contemporary
politics that the snp will win a
majority at the hollywood elections next
may and then nicholas durgan will then
demand a second independence referendum
i mean the pressure she
will come under from with within her own
party
means that demand will come early so
2021 or
very early in 2022. i think in those
circumstances
the uk government will be able to push
it back by saying look
both governments right now should be
concentrating
on the recovery from coronavirus dealing
with the economic and social scars that
it has left behind
rather than an independence referendum
uh talking to people who've done
focused groups of undecided voters up
there
that argument seems to land fairly well
with that crucial group of voters
the more difficult question is how do
you keep saying this
how valid is that as an argument in 2023
or 2024
and i think there the uk government is
going to have to do something
that is is not something that excites
tories or excites boris johnson i think
it is going to have to look at the whole
constitutional framework of the uk
i think it's going to say look we i
think it's basically got to buy time
it's got to say look let's have a
constitutional convention
let's discuss what we're going to do
about extra powers for these new mayors
in england
you know all of these kind of issues
because i think that
this support for independence to a quite
remarkable extent is built on the back
of nicolas sturgeon's popularity
and so i think like mr mccall but it is
worth with the unionist side just
waiting for something to turn up
whether it be something that damages
nicola sturgeon's popularity
of the tolls of office taking part or
issues in our own party i mean
our kind of undercover story i think is
the fact that in the recent
uh snp internal party elections uh
rivals of nicola sturgeon are sending
some quite key positions
we haven't seen the whole alex salmond
um
issue play out with the inquiry at
hollywood so
i think that the union side should be
aiming to buy time
because it is undoubtedly nicholas
sturgeon herself
personally that is driving the support
for independence i mean i think a very
good compliment to
emily's work is some focus groups done
by the group called these islands
and it is quite remarkable because what
it illustrates is that when you
say talk to voters about undecided
voters about the currency question that
you rightly raised andrew
he's going to say well things like well
nicola would have thought about that
and so i think you've got to try and buy
some time because if you had a
referendum
with nicola sturgeon in her current pomp
i think it would be
very very very hard setting for the
unionist side
casey the tourists have a problem in
dealing with this which i think is
probably insoluble for them unless
they do something very dramatic and that
is that all the polling and anecdotal
evidence suggests
that going into bat for the union to
save the union
when your leader is boris johnson is
a major disadvantage for you he just
does not
pull well north of the border and i
think there is a
well-held view by many uh particularly
scottish tory mps
i've had as uh scottish tory mp make the
point to me
that you can't have a referendum while
boris johnson is prime minister
they put it quite bluntly um they think
you have to wait for one of either
nicola sturgeon or boris johnson to
change
ideally both and they think that would
probably help the unis side
um and i think there is a probably a
more widely held view overhead which is
ultimately
there are lots of tory mps who would
rather push the referendum until there's
a labor government
now that's not because they want it to
necessarily be labour's problem i'm sure
there's a little bit of that no one
wants to be the prime minister
who potentially loses scotland and but i
think it's because
there is a sense that there will be a
better chance of you know
winning that vote from the eunice if you
had a labour prime minister around the
tory one
i think there are tory politicians that
are seen to pull well in scotland
it's interesting that some of the
figures involved in advising the
government on this question
rishi sunak as someone who uh i think
scottish tory mp is very keen to be seen
visiting them
i think there's less keenness for boris
johnson but there are a few cabinet
ministers that i think do play well
there
so i don't think that you know there's a
blocker of anyone tory but definitely as
you say there is a boris johnson problem
and i think
that's become more acute james final a
point to you we know
that scotland voting to remain in the eu
england voting against was a
defense it kind of changed the
constitutional nature that was a
a big change compared to 2014 indeed
when the union has said
the only way to ensure that scotland
stays in the eu
is to vote for the union uh so that's
changed
but i wonder if it's changed in another
way the british establishment comes
through in the cover story of the
spectator
which i thought was incredibly defeatist
uh in his approach to the
to the union which is that a lot of
remainers
including the the author of the
spectator cover piece
a lot of remainers seem to think you
know what we are for the union we
supported the union we backed in 2014
but you made such a stupid mistake you
the united kingdom and voting to leave
the eu
it would almost serve you right if
scotland
was to leave the united kingdom so their
hearts aren't in it anymore
and that's split off a chunk of the
british establishment
from the unionist an enthusiastic union
aside
james yeah look i mean the one it would
be very hard to claim that brexit had
been a success
if it led directly or indirectly
to the breakup of the 300-year union
between
england wales and scotland i mean i
think that that would that would
clearly mark it out as a failure i think
that is a problem
i i think there is an interesting
question here which is
you know does if there is a brexit deal
which i think mary i mean i don't i
think it's far from cersei but i think
it looks
more likely than it has done for a
little while
and more likely than not at the moment
does the combination of a brexit deal
and if this oxford vaccine is a is
approved so you have a kind of
a a british vaccine and the british
state
successfully manages to roll it out does
that begin to
change some of those arguments uh i also
think that there is
i also think one of the the great skills
of the scottish national party
has been to suggest that it is somehow a
a more sophisticated form of nationalism
a kind of a kind of social democrat
nationalism
rather than the kind of nationalism that
establishment figures
are uncomfortable with but i think i
think you do see that that mask
slips occasionally i thought it was very
telling that
the western city of the snp in blackfoot
tweeted as a photographer who just sent
a perfectly
beautiful picture of the scottish night
sky saying
you come from southern england how are
you taking this photograph in scotland
given the coronavirus regulations
this photographer turned up had moved up
to scotland and was resident
you know they're in complete compliance
with the regulations so
sometimes that mask does slip and i
think there is an interesting question
which is
you know when this question gets real
when it really is when it isn't when
this isn't a way of saying
well brexit wasn't a good idea or a way
of
of kind of tweaking a westminster
government's tale when it really is the
question
are you going to break up these bonds
that have lasted
that that lasted for 300 years are you
going to
break up uh not only an economic
military and political union but also a
social union i mean one of the
talking about the christmas grown the
virus restrictions one of the reasons
why those had to be done on a
four-nation
approach all of the uk moving in the
same way
was because so many people visit
families in other parts of the uk at
christmas
are you really going to to to
to to render all of that asunder i i
wonder whether at that point people pull
back and
in 2014 what you saw in the campaign was
essentially undecided voters
or lightly decided voters as you might
put it move from no to yes during the
campaign i wonder whether
come the campaign this will obviously
need to happen for the union to survive
you'll see some of those votes some of
the undecided or lightly decided voters
move back to the unionist side when the
full reality
of uh of independence the currency
question
all of these issues eu membership begin
to really really register
no i i think all these are points that
have yet really to come into
play james and in the argument which is
why i think
if you're a unionist defeatism although
you have a you have a mountain to climb
now it's going to be
much much tougher but i don't think
defeatism is merited
uh 8 billion of oil revenues in 2014
solved all sorts of problems for the snp
that's not there anymore
uh a scotland outside the uk
but a member of the eu or england
outside the eu
does mean some kind of border uh between
scotland and england
that wasn't really an issue in 2014
either and the currency question remains
seriously unresolved too and that
matters for the older
age group as well so there are many
things still to talk about and we shall
see how it goes on
james katie emily i know you're very
busy i'm going to let you go now
and move on to our final third section
of the day here on spectator tv but
before i do
just one more reminder to subscribe to
the spectators youtube channel it's free
then you'll never miss a new episode of
spectator tv because you always get
reminded that there's one
has just hit youtube and you can do so
by subscribing
hit the subscribe button in the bottom
right corner of the screen
now in may a black man called george
floyd was killed at the hands or should
i say knee
of american police his death triggered
months of protest
sometimes violent and destructive many
also peaceful
and gave renewed impetus to the black
lives matter movement as ever
the uk imported the cultural wars of
america it wasn't long before statues
here were being toppled and calls to
defund the police were levied at the
met though they didn't get very far in
mainstream politics
now underlying much of these activists
worldview is so-called
critical race theory now you might be
familiar with some of it already
that western institutions are inherently
racist
that white people are structurally
privileged
that the british syllabus in schools and
universities is
colonized it's a controversial theory uh
many have criticized it is popular in
many academic circles and among
some activists but is it right is it a
theory of substance who better to ask
than trevor phillips
former chair of the equality and human
rights commission
one of the authors of the 2010 equality
act trevor phillips thank you for
joining us here on spectator tv
uh just mark my card give us a better
summary of critical race theory than the
one i just gave
thank you andrew thank you for inviting
me and i wouldn't even dream of trying
to
better your summary it was pretty damn
good um
i think the way that i look at it is
this as you will
undoubtedly know i'm pretty much a
skeptic of critical race theory
and i'm a skeptic for this reason if i
were a white nationalist who wanted to
discredit
the progressive anti-racist movement i
would invent
critical race theory why number one
it says to white people you were born
with original sin
and there is absolutely no way that you
will ever shed
that sin so give up already
uh you are just racist and basically the
only thing you can ever do
uh in one of the bibles of critical race
theory um
robin d'angelo's uh book uh white
fragility
she says the only thing white people can
do is be a bit
less white by which she means a bit less
racist
uh secondly the other reason the second
reason i did
i dislike it is that it's antithetical
to scholarship
i mean one of the key aspects of the
text of critical race theory is that it
has to have
no data uh data is uh
an and an obsession with words i think
is the expression
are said to be uh characteristics of
white
supremacy so actually what critical race
theory is based on
is narrative anecdote what happened to
me
and my feelings and actually all of this
all of this adds up to two things one is
distraction from real issues like pay
gaps and so on
and secondly an obsession with
individual feelings
none of which none of which will change
a single thing
for people of color on either side of
the atlantic
let me unroll some of these things but
before i do trevor
one of the things that strikes me about
but particularly it's depiction of
flights
uh that they are just irredeemably
racist and there's not
really much they can do about it except
to the uh
the margins it reminds me of a
calvinistic
uh predestination it doesn't matter how
you behave in this world you want
it's predestined whether you get into
heaven or not it doesn't really matter
and there's a bit of that about critical
race theory
well look i mean let's be clear it's a
scam
it is straightforwardly a scam uh you
only have to go back to reading
tom wolf's uh male mowing the flag uh
um uh malmo flat catchers in which he
describes that the way the black
panthers
essentially took down uh leonard
bernstein
and white new york society and played on
their guilt
in order to raise money for the panthers
by the way i'm full of admiration for
the enterprise
but this has absolutely nothing to do
with improving the situation
for people of color and here is the
other thing which i think is
particularly pernicious
it makes the issues of race equality
entirely
about white people it is entirely about
what white people do
entirely about what white people feel
people like me
simply become pawns or bystanders
who sit here begging you andrew please
be
nicer to us that's a real problem with
critical race theory
it's great for the academics who sell
books and can go around
go around guilt-tripping white people
but for most people of color
no difference whatsoever no i take your
point because it does kind of everything
is benchmarked against white
and it doesn't deal with all the huge
inequalities we see in britain's ethnic
communities
say between a kid from china angle of
chinese parents and a kid
from anglo-bangladeshi parents none of
that seems to
to matter at all one of the things i
mean i'm not qualified to say whether
it's right or wrong but one of the
things that depresses me
about critical race theory is that it
seems to pay
no regard to the progress that has been
made in a country like britain
now we know we have still a long way to
go and there's a lot more we need to do
for opportunities
and deal with racism where it still
exists and no one can deny
that it doesn't but you're you i was
brought up in the 50s and 60s you you
were brought up
not that much later we know how
much this country has changed and
changed for the better and
it seems to me if you say nothing's
really changed then you
you just kind of give up whereas if you
think actually you know we've done quite
well we could
have done better we've done quite well
let's do better now
that's a message of hope yeah um by the
way just if i can just make one point to
you andrew and also to your
listen you began that question by
slightly apologizing for being white
you don't have to mate honestly honestly
it's cool i'm
i'm you know i'm chilled with it it's of
course you're never therefore going to
be as handsome
or as strong or run as fast as me but
that's you know that's your problem
i've learned to live with that for quite
a while now yeah you'd have to apologize
for it
um but i think i think your point is a
very important one and from
the point of view of somebody like me
in my family on the 10th of 10 children
my
parents and my oldest brother who my
brothers who are very active in the
anti-racist movement in
the 50s and 60s it's kind of
disrespectful to them
every time i hear one of these people
say oh nothing has changed
they literally had no i idea my brother
ran home
from school every day being chased by
teddy boys
you know my eldest brother ended up in
wakefield prison
for his anti-racist activities so
i think it's utterly disrespectful to
our parents and our forebears to be
going around
saying oh nothing has changed and by the
way this isn't another
facet of the way that the whole black
lives matter movement has essentially
been taken
by white people because they feel it's
okay to disrespect us it's okay for them
to go on twitter and call me a [ __ ]
because that black lives matter gives
them license to it
but there's another very important point
which i think ought to be made here
the problem with a lot of the black
lives matter propaganda is it does not
recognize that britain is a very
different place to the united states
and here is one extremely i think
significant
uh factor in this country they're on
getting on now for a million people who
have both white
and black parents or grandpa
grandparents
that has not happened voluntarily
anywhere in the world
south africa has mixed race brazil has
mixed race
populations the united states but
they're all at a croatian and slavery
this is the only country
in which a population of that kind of
that size has emerged
since the war and somehow saying to
those
people actually your mum is just a basic
a racist because of what she is
just i mean it's sickening no no
intermarriage has been hasn't that been
a great british success story
well you know we can we can talk about
the details of it but the fact is it's a
particular
thing about that's happened in britain
that we ought to recognize we don't know
by the way what this group of people are
really going to emerge like and how
what they're going to be like i don't
know what it feels like to have
two different heritages in my background
my children do
and i think that will make them very
different people to me but we don't yet
quite know
what that represents i would think it
will probably make them 21st century
that's the way it's got i wonder if
there isn't an even bigger agenda
be behind the not so much black lives
matter
but after this whole critical race
theory
because it does seem almost to try to be
aiming daggers at the very
heart of our being and our existence in
our history
so britain it will always be
irredeemably bad because of the british
empire it's just something we can never
shake off end of and if you look at the
new york times the
1619 project which was inspired by a lot
of critical
race theory they picked 1619 a very
important date
many people did not know enough about it
was the first slaves
arrived in the united states it is a
critical day it is the original sin of
the united states
but it then goes on to to to to argue
that the purpose of the revolu american
revolution in 1776
was not to free america from a colonial
york
and become an independent self-governing
country it was because
the slave owners were frightened that
britain was going to abolish
slavery so they had to break from the
british to preserve slavery now as a
someone who knows quite a lot about
american history uh i can tell you
that's
complete nonsense there are a couple of
slave owners
in the south who might have seen it that
that way and actually britain's
anti-slavery
uh credentials were nowhere near strong
enough in 1776
to be able to con conclude that but if
you see what they've done
the very foundation of the united states
is not built on freedom anymore or in
becoming
an independent country it's built to
preserve
slavery that goes to the very roots of
the country
yes and that this this relates to two
specific two points that i've
made one is the complete lack of
scholarship i mean it's just
as you say it's complete drivel um and
actually their understanding
of the slave experience is utterly
deficient
um i mean for example one of the things
that nobody really talks about
is the fact that um when we talk about
slavery today
in this country and stomachs in the
united states what people are reflecting
and thinking about is slavery in the
caribbean rather than the united states
now this this is a rather kind of geeky
point but most
uh american slavery was cotton and
tobacco slavery
small farms almost no
american uh plant of farms
were huge you know like you see and gone
with the wind with a thousand slaves and
so on
i think probably a fewer than out of uh
forty five thousand they're fewer than a
few hundred that had more than a hundred
slaves
whereas in the caribbean these were huge
factories with thousands of slaves
so they're understanding and this is
important because
actually what is true about the united
states and i think they the black lives
matter movement of mr trick in this
is that the terrorful african americans
occurred
after the abolition of slavery that is
when the kkk emerged
that is when the lynchings happened and
what we're seeing now with the police
is an inheritor of that rather than
slavery and i think they've just
missed a trick actually because they
haven't understood
the story but more i guess more
importantly than that
um politically we'd think of black lives
matter as
or we talk about it as though it's an
inheritor of the martin luther king
tradition it isn't
we should think of black lives matter
much more like extinction rebellion
because a basic proposition is like with
extinction rebellion
you can't have um you can't have a green
world under capitalism the the
blm line is you cannot have an
anti-racist
society uh under capitalism
never mind the fact that in cuba there's
still never been
much of a black presence in the
leadership after her how many years a
slave
of uh of socialism ditto
you know my brother got beaten up in
moscow long before that was happening
here
i mean they want
they're being used essentially as a
front for people
who want to overthrow things as they are
and in a way that's
one of the reasons i slightly resent it
that actually
these guys don't really care very much
about whether black people
are uh advanced or not what they want is
for us to be
a battering ram for their desire to
change society
i'm not against that you know i'm i'm
i'm a lefty
but do it honestly don't use us as a as
a pawn
i i certainly think it's true that
martin luther king would not have been
a supporter of critical race theory i
wonder though just finish up on this
point slightly left field
i wonder if malcolm x would have been a
supporter of critical race theory
well funnily enough i i reviewed a new
biography there's a new biography out of
a very
interesting biography it's a really
interesting biography um
i think that malcolm x would not have
been a supporter of black lives matter
because he wouldn't have liked the in
discipline of the movement
i mean he believed strongly in proper
discipline
i think he would have seen
some sort of commonalities with critical
race theory
in the middle part of his career because
his view was you couldn't trust whites
and therefore we need to be separate
from from them
and in that sense the notion that you
know whites carry this
original sin he called blew up you know
people quote
uh by any means necessary all the time
they don't quote him saying whites are
blue-eyed devils
very much uh he believed all of that
however of course
after he had gone to mecca
had hajj gone round uh with
the seven hills with hundreds of
thousands of people of all background he
wrote about this incredibly movingly
he dropped the whole idea that whites
are
intrinsically bad you can't mix with
them all that kind of stuff
um so i think at the end of his life
short life unfortunately
he would have been really pretty hostile
to critical race theory
and also he would have recognized them
for chances yes
exac and i think it was a pity was a
short life because he was an evolving
person
and uh and he had still so much more to
contribute
trevor i we could talk all day about
this it's been a joy to have you
on tv come back and see us again it's
always
great to listen to you trevor phillips
there thank you very much so our thanks
to all of our guests today
and once again to our very special
sponsor charles stanley
charles sandy is one of the uk's oldest
uh and leading wealth management firms
indeed is one of the oldest firms on the
london
stock exchange as always please send us
your thoughts
to spectator tv and spectator dot co dot
uh
uk we want to do better we know we can
we're interested in what you have to say
a lot of your comments have been very
constructive and we hope that you'll
join us again next thursday for another
the week in 60 minutes until then
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you